gang christmas came early this year
cause the are you garbage special is on
youtube right now yeah guys go share
with your friends hit them up in the
group chat tell people who aren't
familiar with the show this is a perfect
way to introduce them check it out it's
a good time a lot of laughs thanks for
watching love ya welcome to another
exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back to everybody's favorite new
podcast this is r u garbage sure is it's
a little show we sit down with your
favorite comedians and we find out if
they grow up to be classy or they're
just a big old piece of [ __ ] yep i'm
your host stage foley coming at you on a
beautiful day down here in aunt hoody's
basement
she is uh off to florida oh really
spring training okay pitchers and
catchers she wants to get there early
beat the other broads out reports early
yeah absolutely it gets knocked up there
you go then we got some [ __ ] mlb
money coming in
yeah you're keeping that staying at
right now closer cash
my co-host is coming at you from across
the table so you know what that means
it's a family episode we're going to be
answering your questions he is an
international businessman he is abraham
lincoln to me as far as i am concerned
you're a vampire
[Laughter]
that's kj hey gang thanks for tuning in
as always please make sure you rate
review subscribe over there on the
itunes even though it don't matter drop
a review
tell him we should i tell him kippy sent
yeah uh
uh
full video available on youtube as you
know those numbers are true the roof
cooking daddy and why are they cooking
why oh why are they cooking i am turnt
oh anybody from the audience want to
anybody in the bat i'm right here
i'm right here are you garbage special
the fat gentleman in the front
[Laughter]
ken bones in the front
are you garbage comedy special out there
on youtube yeah hooking cooking doing
good zombies happy with the zombies
streaming now streaming now streaming
it's nice that's pretty good t-bone put
that in the in the in the little clip
the little trailer i love streaming now
streaming pretty good yeah uh and then
obviously patreon.com of course i don't
know
some of you i mean obviously not
everybody's well-versed on patreon
i would say
if you're not parents look like i'm an
alien like patreon i would say if you're
not just check out the landing page pop
over there start seeing pop over there
the episodes some of the numbies that
we're doing a thing it's a good product
they got we're they're a lot of good a
lot of good content over there
hundreds of hours of content millions
billions trillions zillions yeah so much
you'd never get to it yeah you'll never
if you watch it you will get through it
how about a nice quick shout out to our
producer shortener the magic man talking
about the smash makes us all look good
very talented individuals wearing
sweatpants and dress shoes right now
t-bone mcscruffins toby
mcmullen what's up dudes brother ah
attention's in the studio are running
high after a little lunch hour viewing
party yeah
[Laughter]
watching the old stuff
we watch each other's old sketches let
me tell you they all suck ass it wasn't
good
kippy is wild it wasn't as bad as that
lunch you recommended that's the last
time you get to recommend lunch
lunch
with the jersey mics will you knock it
off no i i picked one one place that's
nine places so i don't feel like which
that's weird that's lame that's
futuristic [ __ ] yeah they opened up like
there's no buffalo wild wings over there
i'll tell you that right now where the
[ __ ] where the tv's huh the tv i don't
think what do you mean there's no
buffalo wild wings over there jesus i
was still doing it for a bit yes sir oh
i don't understand these are why the
sketches weren't that good back in the
day yeah you were acting in them
i can't stop
[Laughter]
insisting on doing everything in a
british accent
should we do that on patreon maybe
release those old apps those old
sketches maybe listen
some of them i would
they're all very very bad we look
not good we were trying we tried we were
trying i mean this is also we're one two
years into comedy two years ago you were
about four or five but still
sorry enough i just got out of grad
school
it was it was uh some of them are tough
ones that i completely even forgot we
ever spent like weeks on weeks months
arguments fighting screaming thinking
that this was gonna get us over with it
that was the saddest every detail was it
the saddest thing or is that the
mentality that you need looking back the
saddest thing to me was like we did you
know we did a video for a blog
around philly
and i remember i was we were thinking
like man if this goes well you came in
and pitched that to me what's next i
pitched it to you you would flip you you
wouldn't flip there we go you would flip
ask for a sit down with me and cotton at
the raven before the raven it was like
five six o'clock and you guys pitched us
the idea
yeah i'm not listen i'm not gonna say a
conversation didn't happen back at my
dad kippy ryan pitching me
[Laughter]
believe this now it worked for this
[ __ ] guy what the [ __ ]
he's gonna be my backup dancer
now he's signing my checks yeah
he only got five percent bozo
welcome to chess records idiot
[Laughter]
i thought i was running things all this
time hey that's a computer wasn't
plugged in toby punch in on me in
perpetuity all right
those little words will save your life
big man's out
um listen i wouldn't say
i
pitched you
it wasn't like we were out front like
going over our lines like it wasn't it
wasn't [ __ ] shark tank okay
this is the best i'm gonna do for you
i'm gonna borrow ten dollars off you now
retainer for 400 of the company
you're out front look at it flip don't
[ __ ] me in there all right
listen we want to go with cuban but
we'll take foley if we get them
obviously we want to deal with cuban but
you got matching shirts on
[Laughter]
hey sharks i'm
sweating hey whales
no
we shouldn't post the sketches whale
tank
it's foley's bedroom we shouldn't post
the sketches on patreon what we should
do is like a director's commentary we
sit down and watch them and we put them
up on the screen so that people can
watch along with you guys and then you
guys break down how they were done oh
tell you about the madness behind i
don't mind that that's pretty good that
would be major chicken sandwiches though
that would be that way that would that
would have to be
we'd have to change that i wouldn't be
chilling that wouldn't be every level
either that would be reserved for real
give it as an episode of hard feelings
maybe yeah maybe 10 or 12 it would be at
least that whatever i mean dude we have
uh
such a small percentage of the people
are five dollar patrons so it's like i
mean
90 of the patreons are the ten dollar
level i don't know there's just a lot of
skills to play a fun game was fully
yacked up the night before filming oh
man you've
the fact that you think i pitched you
really bothers me that's we're going to
talk about that all fair for sure
you can't be rewriting history i i i'm
not rewriting this revisionist history
you got over there
i make it sound like the japanese
surrendering
flip right in if that happened i had a
corn cob pipe in my mouth um i wouldn't
say we we didn't pick you guys came in
before you guys you said hey we want to
talk to you
this week when you guys have time we've
made some time you have time
how busy were you running a show
it was an open mic that you would bomb
on
[Laughter]
we had a dj
yeah it was cotton what are you talking
about
a lot of wales
i like wildlife my big man did love
watching i loved them um
but that
man that's probably that's probably
hidden right what i think i lost the pan
i lost the password the yeah access all
of those videos i think yeah and the
only person
that could get them was cotton
like i needed his number like to
authenticate it was him because that
thing went down like your aunt's biscuit
recipe ain't nobody getting that
so
i don't think we i don't know
you you i could get some of them i think
flip worked for the for the place
flipboard for this blog and he said hey
i'm in charge of making this camera
yeah like making con like he was in
charge of the website of like getting
people to the website but it only made
one video i didn't think that was going
to drive traffic
[Laughter]
just set it and forget it one video one
video with three absolute nobodies
like that
like they were gonna break the internet
or something i wonder what the company
thought when they watched that well like
the thing if i remember correctly and
what the company
the blog was just like a thing and like
it wasn't like a front for budweiser or
something like that i don't know i mean
everybody relax
chicken [ __ ] sandwich
what are you doing
what are you doing toby clippy clippy
clippy clippy
yeah
toby
what are you doing timmy
elliott
shout out to our good pal college that
was a this is a specific choice you made
in that scene
let me do it again
this time scottish um
yeah and the idea was like we'll make a
video
and the video was around phil like it
was like philly not jerk because in
jersey this is this is hyper specific in
jersey oh my god how the [ __ ] was
anybody supposed to get that i never
realized it was for like nine people
so philly
uh jersey you can't jersey
but at that time jersey sure was hitting
hard and was like the fist pumping right
go to the club you fist bump so the the
premise of the sketch was these two guys
from jersey
gas stations up to a gas station
we got disco music playing or whatever
it was it was techno text now disco
you're so old dude
so they're right we both have bell
bottoms on
i'm all yacked up i'm jacked up for sure
we are on our way to see a talkie
[Laughter]
we got this going on
whatever it was
and we were all guido'd up yeah and we
can we start beeping the horn like
where's the service
they don't cotton
and then i go and i i put the gas in
like the trunk
we can't figure out where to put the gas
and it's like we're putting it like i'm
like looking in the trunk i'm looking
under the hood i'm under the seat we
can't find it then we find out where it
goes
we think we do and it's the muffler i
put it in the muffler
and like the thing is like i put gas up
the muffler the lightest smoke in the
place and the whole place blows up yeah
and then it says like we philly we pump
our gas
not our fists what was the writing
process on this four or five years
it was in rewrites for a while i gotta
be honest with you we won sundance that
year sorkin did the original draft
it was a little wordy for my taste but
he did take a run at it
zemeckis turned it down
um
but that's and we like the
that was the first thing we worked on
together yeah we weren't even friends
really i mean
no i mean
we weren't
asked me to be your best man that day
that foley was your first name
please you have to pitch me on this
thing
so we're going to talk about that for
sure
listen here
i've never pitched you forever get it
out there yeah you did
you asked me for my help
you said you wanted to collaborate as
equal partners okay collaborate fine
collecting
you you pitched me the idea
there's you're sitting down you're
coming to sit down bully's eating
chicken tenders from another table
you've always come into my business
excuse me ma'am
[Laughter]
i'm holding like a cigarette
this is a write-off right
it was a fun day but that was probably
it's funny because that's where like the
stress and the
all that stuff we cared
so so much and like that's that well
that that's what i'm saying when you
guys were when we were watching those
videos just now
it really
took me back to a place i in my stomach
that's why i wasn't really partaking
with you because i
literally got transplanted back to a
place that wasn't like scary like i
didn't feel that in my stomach of like
this is gonna be big
this gas pump video is gonna be big for
us so like that thinking of the next
thing maybe if we do this one it'll lead
to that one and then this thing and that
and it was just like theoretically
once i lost all creative control things
seemed to work out
i think that feeling in your stomach was
the party subject
[Laughter]
porky
yeah i was the fat one
it's crazy but he was mean cotton were
fat he was doing all right back then
yeah bizarre is a good kid
his hair
i like your hair better now way better
than back then it was too long and there
was too much of it
i went from having too much it did not
enough in a way in a weird way there was
like you had a ripped up teddy bear on
your head
now now you have like i told you it's
kind of sexy bruce willis
i'm listening what are you pitching me
i'm about to pitch a ted
uh but like you keep it you weren't
cutting it like that no plus your head
was like in different shape
[Applause]
i don't know if the plates had set yet
i was still at a soft spot
his head was that was like the pain i
don't hold don't touch him at the top of
the head his head was like the pangaea
it was still shifting and cooling
um before the before the meteor that
killed the dinosaurs
every time he has a thought that's how
old my head is
my bomb from the neck down i'm 35.
um paleolithic period
no my hair
i've always not obviously my hairline's
thinning uh that's not yeah that but my
hair i've said this but my hair is very
it's like
doll's hair my buddy it's like really it
was too weird because it was long and it
was there was a lot of it that i didn't
have a receding hairline but and i
didn't product wasn't a thing you had
real crooked cop vibes yeah i'm
listening yeah
but like low level like you shake it
down like a philosophy like a doughnut
shop or something
yeah
i want three glaze
[Laughter]
every month on the 31st deliver it to
this address
um yeah my hair was bad my hair was
tough i was very overweight um
[Music]
yeah that was it that was about it a lot
of burnies i was i think if i stayed in
philly i would have i wouldn't want to
see my i mean i moved to new york i
moved to new york i ended up losing a
bunch of weight
got a nice dame
locked it down quit barney's for a long
time
you know i got my [ __ ] together if i was
in philly i would be just like
i'd be i would be the size of you if i
was in philly i would be this because
that's that would be the size of a house
so what if i was still in philly you
would probably be small maybe cutting
you out of a window
yeah fire department would have to come
i don't know but you were you were doing
all right in philly yeah like size what
like you know you were just like regular
chubby yeah was it husky boy husky
they're a husky boy sure um confused
lost scared
worried and they were dire times dark
times
years years
of of misery
self-imposed uh-huh i also too remember
like this is i've been a little trip
down memory lane but then when we were
in new york we were just talking about
we're doing shows at the village lantern
those days of like those days were wild
to me because
success
was like it sounds so corny but it was
so close
like tangible like you were like it was
doing shows it was simple we weren't
close to success but it was around this
yes and you're like oh there's [ __ ]
whatever dan soder said like
something or you know yanny or somebody
like this just dismantling
but so i remember being like there's no
way i remember sitting there like doing
the math of like okay cool i made
500 this year doing comedy or something
not bad grossed you know what i mean not
even net
and i'm like how am i going to turn this
into a viable living like because i was
getting serious with the lady you know
we were flying back and forth and stuff
i had a good day job that was paying all
the bills like for like but you were
miserable oh god
um
and just being like how the [ __ ] am i
going to make the turn
how am i going to make as much as i make
now
ever in comedy like i'm like it's
at that rate pre-pandemic
it was impossible to wrap my head around
that i started making fun of a fat guy
[Laughter]
two years ago my goal was to figure out
how to make 18 000 in comedy that's
pretty good i i've i don't know if i
ever said this on two more years maybe
i wanted two more specials let's see
what happens
and now you're making nine
halfway there buddy i'm rooting for you
oh we're fighting the good fight i got
that bonus
um
my friend was like you got to put that
in the bank i was like the bank we're
talking about kings
cut that [ __ ] in my freezer i mean for
legal purposes i'm going to report that
to the irs uh the bank what am i going
back to school this is pocket cash
how do i report that to you no one's
coming at you for a jihad
it's it's only it's on camera it's 10 or
over livestreaming scripted show
that was prop money prove me wrong
[Laughter]
picture a shack on those bills
those are dave and buster bucks
self-sustaining economy box of awesome
boxes spoke post box of awesome pretty
cool box of awesome that's gonna be my
hardcore band box off awesome
ooh box awesome is a sweet name yeah and
a fantastic fantastic idea put the
coolest stuff in one box and send it out
we're talking winter cocktails cozy
threads what else stuff outdoor it's
cool guys shit's grooming cool guy [ __ ]
box of awesome box of awesome cool guy
[ __ ] it's leather apron cool yes that's
the kind of cool yeah but not without
like would not be pretentious dorky it's
very cool yeah to get started head to
box of awesome.com uh take the quiz your
answers are gonna help take the quiz
they want to find they want to know
about you pick the right box for you um
each box only costs 45 bucks but has
over 70 dollars worth of gear
inside it's free to sign up you can skip
skip a month cancel at any time like i
said they sent us a bunch of stuff got
the hammock cool guy stuff the bag's
right over there by the way it's tight
um plus with each box of awesome we'll
be smarting you'll be supporting small
businesses 90 of everything that comes
in your box of awesome is from a small
up-and-coming brand look at that uh
get 20 off your first monthly box when
you sign up at box of awesome.com enter
promo code garbage to check out that's
box of awesome dot com code garbage 20
off your first box do it yeah
butcher box put your box butcher box
butcher box does this have anything to
do with with the truckload of meat that
i got in my freezer i mean it's a wild
what they said beef
a chicken whole chicken i got a whole
family's a chicken wild caught
sockeye
salmon or if you're from my household
salmon salmon couple of salmons in a
freezer really yeah it depends who
you're talking to you call it poop too
or pork
we call it pork and they sent us some
boneless pork chops dude cooked up
d-lish yeah it's great they make meal
prepping uh easy take the difficultness
out of it uh butcher boxes subscription
service that takes the guesswork out of
finding high quality meat butcher box
sources their meat from partners with
the highest standards for quality no
more searching the grocery store for 100
grass-fed beef free-range organic
chicken wild-caught seafood and more
come straight to your door just the
ground beef is worth it alone it's
fantastic
we make spaghetti with that oh it's so
good yeah nice bolognese delish each box
contains 8 to 14 pounds of meat
depending on the box you choose that's
enough for 24 individual meals packed
fresh shift frozen for convenience you
know save time and money on your next
trip to the grocery store and you keep
it in the freezer take it out when
you're ready to cook easy peasy bang for
a limited time butcher box is offering
new members a great deal for the new
year sign up at butcherbox.com ayg and
you'll receive the ultimate new year
bundle in your first box this deal
includes ground beef chicken thighs pork
butt that's more than seven pounds of
meat added to your first box for free
get this new year's bundle before it's
gone by going to butcherbox.com ayg do
it do it and when i started when we
started the idea of starting the podcast
and the patreon the patreon
was within like if we were like hey in a
couple of years or like two years
imagine if the patreon made a thousand
dollars i remember saying that to you
i'm like if we each made 500
that would be like
i would be a pig and [ __ ] i would be
like i'd be able to
stop i don't know if i was working
part-time yeah i was probably just
started working part-time from full-time
so poor
so [ __ ]
dirt dirt poor god damn
holy [ __ ] he's a real bummer this
episode
i'm having fun
i don't know what this loser is talking
about i was flush with cash you're still
poor what are you talking about
but i'm spending
i'm stimulating the economy is what i'm
[ __ ] doing stimulating your clitoris
i don't know what that means
i put it back into the business
the business spend money to make money
the business of being awesome
yeah
which is why a wild turn of events
insane thank you to the [ __ ] army of
garbage baby fantastic
i'd still be making shitty [ __ ]
sketches
would we
we'd be doing something i don't know i
don't let the pandemic change things if
the pandemic never happened
i don't know what i don't think i would
come back to knowingly the landscape now
what would you be doing
what are you talking about
if we never start if the pandemic never
happened i mean we started already
garbage
never happened we would no i'm saying
this happened but i'm saying ayg didn't
happen
am i me or am i somebody else you're you
have a mustache
you can have whatever you want milk milk
mustache it's like the metaverse um i'm
just saying
if the pandemic happened right right but
ayg didn't happen if okay so the
pandemic so you're coming back now and
you're like
still waiting for spots fighting for
like i'm way ahead of you so what you're
saying is
we started we started our new garbage
right before the pandemic if at the
pandemic you were like
you know i don't know what i'm gonna die
i might just go home for a little while
just to wait till if we didn't [ __ ]
charge ahead start doing two episodes a
week
an episode of hard feelings every day
i'm just saying imagine coming back from
the pa obviously
new york landscape has changed there's
less shows
there's less spots going around i would
have i would have probably dipped out to
hawaii
oh that's pretty good you always have in
your head that's a parachute you're
pulling no not at all not at all but i'm
saying looking back on it back then but
i'm saying that if we packed it in it's
no i'm not saying you packed it in i'm
saying we just never attempted to start
are you garbage
right uh-huh pandemic happens you were h
fully
pre-ayg
uh-huh pandemic happens everybody's off
stage for six months a year whatever
things slow like i'm saying imagine like
fighting for spots or like waiting
around
with no road work
that's what i'm saying maybe i would
have never came back from hawaii yeah i
would have went out for one last wave
the big one
like point break
damn
another place we use something
like that but cooler
there's a guy riding you
just me and swayze making out a little
bit mean forward
when i ride this one i don't [ __ ]
know man thanks for playing along
um
yeah and it wouldn't happen because we
would we'd be different people if we
packed it in i remember the [ __ ]
conversation you were like we're not
[ __ ] letting this go it's a [ __ ]
good idea i love you you love me okay
hold on
i did not pitch you on this i know that
much
yeah we had that conversation we're like
[ __ ] it let's go and i was like [ __ ] it
let's go that's what we did
now we're here with the army of garbage
the [ __ ] best in the world and t-bone
mcstuffins on the team never liked the
guy good kid me either
not a fan
like when bruce bought and brought in
the big man to the band
clarence clemons
playing the sax
i'm the sax guy
clarence clemens was a big part of that
sound
cool dude too
not around anymore but still what are
you going to do you just talking about
hootie and the blowfish what's going on
what's happening
dolphins made me cry speaking of philly
do you remember the hooters at all
and we danced by the wave on the ocean
romance we were like they were a huge
philly band and they they became like an
actual band in the 80s oh no oh that was
always the hooters hooters
yeah
well where would they play like regional
they became like an actual band you know
what i mean like
i'm gonna like go with the blue up what
choose your words wisely
they became an actual band and blew up
are two different things the hooters had
a big hit a big
worldwide hit did you say like a double
d how big was it
t-bone you on the hooters worldwide hit
and we danced was a big hit i think it
might have been a number one hit
and we holy [ __ ] they they have
millions and millions of streams on
spotify see 18 and a half million 20 and
a half million 20 28 million
shout out to the hooters
oh my god these guys look like vampires
dude they're old now what do you want
from them
yeah still kick your ass
uh i don't know maybe i know some of
their tracks some of their licks
some of their
so yeah
um
anyway
what would we have done
would have done this way would work that
a million times out of a million what
never tire never back down we would have
muscled through yeah could have figured
something out
crime probably yeah at this point i
would be a white-collar criminal
i would be skimming someone's books for
sure
i'd be pinching out of their savings
account
making dummy statements giving them to
somebody meanwhile i'm out in the cayman
somewhere
i'm not gonna say i never thought about
that riding two jet skis
uh like water skis yeah i don't know
it's just weird to think i mean because
it all you know i don't know
i've never really looked up from it all
if that makes sense i'm like just
starting to now although you're starting
like looking up and being like oh [ __ ]
it's very strange yeah very strange
feeling i said i still say that to like
my wife i'm like this is wild that this
is like
my life very i still can't comprehend
like the other night we dropped the
special right dropped
uh i took my lady out to dinner nice
steak
dinner nice steak dinner threw a t-bone
down her throat um that was a weird
choice of words
sirloin
new york strip
um
out to dinner and i'm sitting there
texting with schultzy at dinner
and i'm like this is a what i literally
was like this is a wild life the fact
that i'm not worried about this bill
being dropped is the first time in 35
years i've you know what i mean your
wife was panicking
she was paying too so
but i'm just saying i'm so conditioned
to like worry about it was always
financing of course he's worried about
finding it do you think i'm talking this
italian brother in therapy [ __ ]
losing it over here
i need a gun to the back of my head
all right
can't come any other way
having any candle wax
oh my god oh no you know what we know
exactly what you mean we all have that
[ __ ] mentality
dude on the drive-in today foley called
the hotel in france
and the desperation in his voice when he
tried to ask her in french if she spoke
english is one of the best things i have
ever i'm trying to [ __ ] be polite man
all right international relations
trying to look you know what i mean
big star go over there that caused an
international incident i don't want to
offend anybody
let alone the queen
[Laughter]
like ew no no that was good but in the
car it was
mercy you said
do you speak english thank you
donde asalo cervicios por favor
maybe
yeah there's plenty of stabbings on the
subway every year
[Laughter]
mr big buggins
heard about enough out of you
a peanut gallery
that was a private call by the way
which i told you
no you did good
yeah
got the room all set up
it's great yeah
why don't you leave tomorrow best
western
best easter
tomorrow
i think right now if you're hearing this
i'm already gone yeah
like a night train gwen in the
summertime
that's my wrestling coach used to always
say it meant like 10 different things
fully get off your back
fully put your clothes back on folks i'm
looking at the guys in the shower
[Laughter]
before we get out of there hey
what'd i tell you about having an
erection
about popping god damn you little creep
i think about popping wood during drills
yeah right now you're fighting an
interpol agent with a magazine
leaving the gas running
in a flat
right right now i'm playing hardball in
an interrogation room
every time we talk about france it ends
up in [ __ ]
foreign commented commented for what we
said like it only takes five seconds
before someone makes a born ultimatum
it's just so good
it's just so good the fat damon
especially
the beer batter supremacy
we have 24 hours to change our identity
dye our hair and get to czechoslovakia
first let's grab a croissant
that damage just you doing food
challenges
[Laughter]
how many snails are they
so we're in the park
at a restaurant
you're eating wild bugs
these goddamn snails are disgusting
it's the zoo [ __ ]
but you're in a swamp right now
dude
fat like i'm fresh
all right
oh
holy hell boys
you usually don't get that nostalgic
what
i don't did in the beginning i know i'm
the uh
but you guys are watching those videos
watching
watching the videos hearing seeing those
comments that were in the videos that i
haven't seen or thought of in a [ __ ]
you know a decade
and thinking
man we shot that
vodka thing uh-huh aye vodka thought
that was like
i thought that was like a movie set but
really yeah there was lights
and i think a guy with a boom mic i mean
i just listened it sounded horrible
it sounded like [ __ ] you know who
directed those
you had a scarf on and it still bothers
me to this day
this [ __ ] jerk-off
showed up to shoot a comedy sketch in a
sky all right look lively yeah i swear
to god short sleeve shirt
short sleeve shirt no i have a crack
jack i had a car to get on or something
like that i had my pants tucked into my
boots like the old days too
looks like david oselznick
and louise
yeah shut up enough showed up yeah has
glasses on
all right can't be a little a little
more what do you think yeah oh yikes
meanwhile i'm like nine people are gonna
see this thing
maybe
maybe nine people will watch it
i mean we had like 15 extras we ordered
a fake glass bottle this is the the
this is the crux almost shut us down
[Laughter]
somebody brought live rounds on on set
too
um
no i think it opened it it was broken
whatever he blamed cassidy though for
sure of course yeah
uh that wasn't my contract back then
three hours berating cassidy
hey after lunch i need i need to take
three hours and just talk [ __ ] to
cassidy make him want to [ __ ] shoot
himself
i love you tommy um
yeah i think it came broken and i was
like oh we're just doomed to be failures
forever
we got we got our money like the budget
on the second we don't think i [ __ ]
knew that on the inside i knew we were
all good you showed up in a scarf you
jerk off i gotta keep up appearances
rally the [ __ ] troops i knew it was a
lost cause i was like 48 at the time
the [ __ ] man
oh were on the back nine already yeah i
was chasing demons trying to [ __ ]
get some ghosts away from me yeah
what was the name of that bar
i could smith smith yeah cause i did a
show there called comedy on the rocks
let me tell you
it saw
how many people showed up that abnormal
was that sold out got me in the rocks it
straight up sucks
that's all you bartenders out there
that's that was brutal
because they didn't even remember that i
remember they wouldn't let you made a
youtube commercial for it though yes you
this
the most interesting man in the world
commercial i don't think funny was one
of his attributes
[Laughter]
the unfunniest man in the world
knockout who's there no one's at this
comedy show they wouldn't let me start
running the raven
which was an open mic in philly
um until i had like proved myself by
running my own show for a little while
you guys randomly was a fortune 500
company meanwhile you guys were getting
25 a show that kept disappearance yeah
i i i stuck in there underage with my
own beer and no one said [ __ ] it was a
mess
cut that
why
see he's still going to keep up some
sort of appearance
i'm still a stock i don't even need the
board members
what i'm going to say what i'm going to
say at the shareholders meeting still
orders run deep i don't know what that
means still waters run deep what does
that mean
there's so much in that sentence right
there really yeah
still waters run deep why is there so
much in that sentence the the fact that
you you go i don't know what still
waters runs deep what does that mean
still waters runs deep is typically a
you know
if in the
actual meaning of it is still waters
like if you're looking at a creek or a
pond or something right not a pond
because there's not a current it's still
at the top but down deep it's ru there's
movement it means what's
on the surface isn't always what's down
below
still waters
they run deep so if you're talking to
like a per when it comes to a person a
quiet person kind of an idiot yeah
he's quiet but he's
smart or in de you know in depth and has
meaning to him there's more than meets
the eye with you it's all on the surface
and it ain't great
[Laughter]
used to say that people who are quiet or
shy are often very intelligent and
interesting
very nice
i see myself like that a little bit oh
really
i'm a director
are you quiet though i have the scarf to
prove it man when you were at fashion
choice in the morning you were like i'm
hitting it like
no i was a self-conscious low
self-esteem [ __ ] mess who didn't know
who he was i was trying to figure myself
out through my art
and my music
and stepped on cocaine
yeah
i never did a lot of step like cocaine
in my life
take that back take that back you piece
of [ __ ]
my guys are good guys
we're kidding
about those guys being good guys
oh they weren't hey gang let's talk
about athletic greens baby ag-1 is a
comprehensive and convenient daily
nutrition with 75 vitamins minerals and
whole food-sourced ingredients made for
just about everybody uh tons of people
are taking come some kind of
multivitamin it's important to choose
one with high quality ingredients that
your body will actually absorb ag-1 is a
small micro habitat with big benefits
it's one thing you can do every single
day that'll take great care of yourself
your subscription comes with a year's
supply of vitamin d which is important
to add in these winter months so you
don't get because we don't get as much
sunlight it's lifestyle friendly whether
you're
keto paleo vegan dairy free or
gluten-free contains less than one gram
of sugar listen guys it's the new year
they were nice enough to send us uh a
package of it i started taking it it's
fantastic i'm going to use it
uh as as the beginning of a new year new
me to get healthy lose a couple of
pounds that you guys have been making
comments about i'm going to use ag
to spearhead the attack
right now it's time to reclaim your
health and arm your immune system with
convenient daily nutrition especially
heading into the cold and flu season
just one scoop and a cup of water every
day that's it there's no need for a
million different pills or supplements
to look out for your health to make it
easy athletic greens is going to give
you a free one year supply of immune
supporting vitamin d and five free
travel packs with your first purchase
all you have to do is visit
athleticgreens.com
garbage again that's athleticgreens.com
garbage to take ownership over your
health and pick up your ultimate daily
nutritional insurance
now back to the show
money never sleeps and cocaine don't
wait
well i'm sorry that i was such a bad
leader back then
i didn't say i agree with that statement
but i did not say that
i mean you did lead us to nine views
i'll give you that
nine more than we would have had
if what
we're gonna drop it it's dropping
tomorrow at noon and then we should wear
it we would drop it and literally the
ticker would not move and you'd be
called i remember you called me the one
is it frozen or something what's
happened i'm like now these are this is
a live look at the numbers here
and they ain't going nowhere was it
algorithms and keywords and [ __ ] back
then too
uh no i think youtube was like a
definitely different landscape back then
i didn't i
didn't really so we just stunk
yeah
and i remember knowingly we stunk oh i
started i knew we were really of course
i'm a human being
and an idiot
yeah dude and there was no competition
on youtube back then it was wide open it
was like jamaican cartoons and [ __ ]
we could have done all right for
ourselves i remember the first time a
kid showed me youtube
it was in uh college
and he showed me uh unforgivable
remember that dude i went to get a
chicken plate i went to get a chicken
sandwich i went on a date someplace in
the mall the dude was so funny like the
first five videos he pulled up youtube
on my computer and then like two days
later i got a virus and i called i'm
like dude what the [ __ ] did you do like
i didn't i was like don't ever put
youtube on my computer ever again
meanwhile now my career's on it
talking about being out of touch with
technology oh [ __ ] no idea what youtube
was
i was playing snoot though heavy
i thought it was a tire place
come on it's pretty
good it's not bad come on
that's comedy on the rocks folks
you mean that would give me that one for
old time's sake
what time's the show start huh comedy on
the rocks i remember we were running the
sound system out of an actual stereo
i swear to god it's gotta be on am i
said
[Laughter]
the ball game kept cutting in
we gotta do the show at nine because
that's what they do their commercial
free block so we don't get commercials
during the walk-up yeah and then and we
we packed the place and we kept uh
uh the thing the speakers kept blowing
out remember like getting known to
follow yell we have to have the sound on
it was she was like shut the [ __ ] up
yeah i got chicken figures i know what
the [ __ ] yeah we took ourselves way too
seriously took ourselves away very sweet
took ourselves very seriously for such a
because that's what it goes back to like
those we thought these opportunities
this show this open mic this
stupid sketch we're making we were like
this is gonna be a thing
that leads this or does something and it
would they never were it's tough look
constant rejection oh god
those sketches that i showed you we had
a meeting with someone from nbc about it
and when they sat down they said which
is like insane but when they sat down
the lady corporate stooge yeah the lady
goes to be honest with you guys i'm a
junior executive i have no power and i
work in the drama department so if you
guys had any questions about like law
and order i can answer those
[Applause]
[Laughter]
jerry orbach real yeah
or is he a robot
i would want to get a job just writing
or box zingers that would be that would
have yeah she got ahead of
herself late
like a school on sunday no class nobody
dropped a zinger over a dead body like
jerry or i love love loved those that's
the prime
law and order come on yeah of course
of course they were great when he could
bend the rules a little bit back yeah
[ __ ] beat up a purple little bit
take it to him
letty still had a couple left in him
yeah he wanted to try him lenny
definitely beat a couple confessions out
of a couple guys yeah they even showed
that a little bit especially like
because he he was dry but he used to be
a drunk oh yeah yeah and they there was
a couple of things i should have drunk
from what the old guys would tell me in
the in the station house yeah that say a
couple of things he said what do you
want from me i was drinking back then if
they opened up a case or something or
like something got tossed out
they like went back to his history well
that's how it should be i'm not a proud
man dude i'm not a proud man either i
tell why i was wearing scarves back then
what do you want from me
first of all i'm pretty sure it was like
august
show up in his scarf got to keep my
throat warm
i got you lunch that night i don't think
so yes i did and then do you remember i
was just thinking about this the other
day here we go what i'm such a bad guy
like nick nolte
tell me no no i don't want to hate you
we're having fun you do not seem to be
i'm having a great time please tell me i
don't want to pay you out come on stop
it all right i guess
toby over the lights that was good catch
me on the two did you do that camera
again
that was really good
you're not the only lesbian here okay
i apologize
um
i shot
the first thing i did on my own
was
transformers one
uh
the hashtag the hash out
that was up here yeah that was the first
thing i did where i was like this is my
i i'm keeping your
barbecue fingers off of it not off of it
but you aren't making the decisions no
you would set it up with uh with an
associative artist from philadelphia yes
it was up here at the time it was up
here at the time we went and pitched him
remember when we went to him yes we went
to his house and we sat outside and
again
yeah i was just he just texted me the
other day that was like the frog that
that was like i don't think we had had
like nice whiskey that was the first
time i might have had just
that was the first time i think i had
whiskey not in a shot glass yeah that
was like when frank lucas brought those
two guys up to test the h out on yeah
exactly getting touching blue
magic uh we were both naked for some
reason
we weren't pinching yeah um it was like
a nice house like yeah you live here
upper west oh dude we were he had that
roof deck i think i was wearing two
different shoes
[Laughter]
i swear to god that was a minute where i
had two slightly different shoes yeah
that man's bad and it's it's classic
foley and then like he's got a nice
apartment in the upper west side not
like insane i put it upper you know new
york upper west side apartment nice
little like roof terrace balcony thing
then his wife comes home
and then we go you know we have the
meeting we walk outside he goes
man what do you think he makes here
just like that i think that's what you
said what do you think he's a
millionaire i'm like i don't think he's
a millionaire
um
but it was the hash out and the idea was
like twitter jokes kind of like a
talking head show it was when like
whatever the mtv shows like guy code and
stuff like that
it was like a talking head real ahead of
this curve
it had just been done
at least i was forward thinking
how for what about what my drama
you just showed me a sketch where you're
supposed to be on a boat and there was a
chalkboard behind you that said boat
all right i don't think i don't think
you're that ahead of your time it's a
think piece
shut up i think it's a piece of [ __ ]
i think this stinks
um
and
so i had everybody come to my apartment
and you had work
you couldn't get you couldn't be there
for it
or you were coming way later or
something something something or like
the next day or something happened you
weren't there at the time and i had it
was like me reggie rosebud
uh cotton
cotton cassidy
a couple other people i think you know
reggie whatever floating around
um
[Music]
and
i got everybody long i spent like 80
bucks or whatever got everybody like
lunch and wings and every dude and you
you
you got so many somebody posted a
picture of me with headphones in behind
the camera and you texted me like who
the [ __ ] do you think you are you get
the [ __ ] out of here i didn't think yeah
i do i hunted
i'm gonna say this as you were yeah it
was like a i was peanut butter and jelly
yeah it was like a who do you think he
got wings without me
yeah it was just funny and i was like
this this is the tides turning big man's
out new young bucks coming in we had the
old bull believe now we want the young
calf
[Laughter]
believe me i'm glad you're at the wheel
i'll be asleep in the back of you
i've been dragging you the past two
years but we know when we get to denver
let me know when weeds legal will you
[Laughter]
somebody bring some eddies to the show
but i love you buddy what a wild [ __ ]
i don't know how we just went all the
way down this memory lane i love you pal
it was a good uh
i wouldn't want it any other way it's
been a hell of a ride
and with that being said this will be
our last episode
you shoot me
same thing i always wanted to watch you
die
they committed take me away
get them boys
you take over like boba fett
nothing no oh god that's funny
good
there's some business to attend yeah we
got to knock out some questions here i
believe so good the good people the
bozos and the homies yeah i think we've
got about 10 minutes left we can run
through some q's i want to hear about
our troubles and and tribunals but a lot
of people a lot of people have it as i'm
like i want to know the origin story
like stuff like that because this is a
very yeah you had it tough in new york
city park let me tell you the story of
another guy who had a hard life this
name was age 40.
okay uh-huh i'm listening that's it yeah
we'll leave it there for now
two-parter
we all had a tough
tough sure
now we're eating jersey mike's for lunch
we're doing all right i had wink stop
never again that boy needed 10 pieces
never again yeah that was the last time
you picked lunch
all right stunk
still love you how did it ever work out
with nbc
what do you got
yeah
i don't think it was nbc it had to be
like local news affiliate
could you meet with the weather guy yeah
i'm john jenkins with sports here i have
this local comedian bozo
there's no way it was proper nbc it
wasn't jack donaghy i know that much
it was it was through the new york
television festival we had they set up
meetings for us with legit nbc funny or
die
[ __ ] ifc all those [ __ ] people who
were trying to make [ __ ] [ __ ] five
ten how 2005.
did you wear a suit no 20
2015 2015.
set up meetings now who would handle the
meetings would it be you
no
really so you weren't you weren't even
the major player in this operation i uh
he was just a ponzi
pawn
no i was
i was the problem patsy i was the
problem solver of the group when it came
to like uh the right why you stink
all right guys we stink what's going on
here i think it's me
i'm not gonna lie i think we all kind of
stink you guys all agree yes okay cool
we got that out of the way
what do you want to do for lunch i say
jersey
by the way i got jersey bikes my
sandwich was lip delicious kippy got
wingstop it's thunk and you got some
cuban sandwich from some offense twist
to my stomach right now
all right all right let's do a couple of
questions and then we gotta get out of
here
all right this one is from nicholas
everfreeze milk
i guess to preserve it
is that a thing no but when i was a kid
i thought that's how you made ice cream
boy was i pissed at the end
eight hours later i'll tell you that
that's a tough popsicle oh sucked that's
what i thought ice cream was it was just
frozen milk yeah
no i don't we never froze that that's
insane ah i told you i think i told you
so we made i had we made ice cream one
time
if we had a babysitter it was like we'll
make our own ice cream and a folgers can
[ __ ] you
never doing that you're not falling for
that [ __ ] that's [ __ ] some broad from
lancaster
trying to save a buck
uh i guess she thought it was gonna be
like a fun activity but
frozen milk no my mother does freeze
some questionable things well she
freezes bread
a lot my mom will do that she would do
that when we were kids you would do like
if like you get like a couple things of
strowman throw one in the freezer and
now but you never eat now you can taste
it it gotta toast it you have to taste
it even then you can still taste it yeah
it's tough tough but she would do it for
the money thing if they were like two
for four and they were like king-sized
jewels you got to do that i get that
those king-sized babies when you were a
kid man they were great yeah
they were long just eating them just a
piece just i used to ball up a piece of
bread ball it off
a little ball a couple of fatties
cheers and bread balls
big fan of the app uh big fan of bread
what can i say yeah uh but she'll do it
now from time to time
cause they don't eat them there's no one
in the house they don't eat that much so
it's like i will say it like for her to
eat a loaf of bread i would you know or
she'll buy it for like the kids or
something and then what i like so
i'll go home she's like there's some
bread in the freezer i'm like i'll go to
walmart you mean the hoth system yeah
thanks yeah get the [ __ ] out of here
never froze that
never froze milk
i don't free [ __ ] meat that's all i'll
freeze now
oh oh by the way i wanted to talk about
this
uh my aunt hits me up really uh
you got a little bit of cash right which
one
one that was successful got you um not
that they're not all successful yeah no
but the yeah we love you she was uh yeah
she was a you know
corporate exec yes say no more she hit
me up hey you got a package coming your
way just an
fyi um
what's it called douglas stakes what is
it omaha stage wow yeah wow i go all
right i don't know i should just say
just a heads up supposed to be there
tomorrow i don't know your schedule i
know you're running around whatever like
i'll be here she goes all right
knock on the door
that white cooler from heaven baby
yeah got some burgers got the whole
[ __ ] nine
and now i got a new cooler for
tailgating there you go we're fishing i
felt
nice i felt like rich trash nothing
wrong with them omaha steaks yeah
all right my girl was like oh we can
keep this as a cooler like she's like
all about like saving it could use it as
a coffee table you put a little ottoman
put a towel over it
like a [ __ ] gentleman
great question this one is a direct shot
at my co-host which i do not approve of
i've never taken a shot at you i think
you're a great guy thank you i
appreciate that and i would agree you've
never taken a shot at me once okay um ad
this is from andrew as an adult people
still call you by your last name instead
of your first name
which
for some reason i agree with this guy
names as you get old nicknames as you
get older
can be tough a tj and rj you've got to
lose that that's in the white collar
world though in the blue collar world
guys that do the living and dying out
there you know you got chicky go talk to
chicky chick straight yeah yeah that's
not good it could be a union guy hard
work yeah i'm just saying
uh nicknames i'm saying last name
you pull it off for some reason i don't
know why
i'm age folding
wait let me see with a scarf let me see
how it looks toby get my scarf
let's go with the red one
uh tell me for some reason it works i
don't know why
like you couldn't he couldn't be
mcmullen yeah i think you and you embody
a foley
there's certain guys so there's certain
people that have certain last names that
are that that just work as a last name
that's always the way yeah my never
doesn't people push it yo ryan and i'm
like what do you do
mullen
cassidy is a cassidy though cassidy
works cotton was a cot cotton worked you
know reggie doesn't conquest doesn't
know it's got to be reggie reggie yeah
reggie reggie works for reggie ian works
for ian
tommy pope works for pope yeah donnelly
works for donnelly finally works for
donnelly gilly gillis works for for
shane i guess irish names it seems
gillis is good yeah where's gillis
where's gillis at where's mcmullen at
hey you wouldn't say that where's toby
he's getting my scarf that's where he's
probably getting a wedgie somewhere
i think he's in a meeting with nbc right
now
that legitimately bothers you so
i'm happy for you
glad it all worked out too yeah
bob you should first look at the doppler
system it bothers me that you and your
bozo friend somehow weaseled your way
into nbc when we had brilliant sketches
that weren't getting any love from the
industry
like that time i was on an imaginary
boat with three of my friends
how do you know it's a boat read the
chalkboard
mr michaels i have to explain everything
to you
[Music]
was it in the city yeah it was in new
york 30 rock
no no no it it was
it it was in a hoboken where was it
one of their satellite campuses yeah
i think it was in a it was in some sort
of like convention spare like a like a
hotel wow this was a time share pitch
what are you talking about literally it
was like industry speed dating it was
like each company had their own table
and you would go
we love you t-bone
maybe all worked out for a reason um all
right this one's from bernie sanders
have you ever smoked a sig inside
recently
recently i don't think i've had a sig
inside now
i don't think i associate with singing
inside people anymore
no or who cause like when i would go to
my friend's house who smoked they would
say yeah you can smoke no one's smoking
inside
yeah but i'm i'm sure of course i'm
trying to say the last time i would
smoke inside is like a buddy's house was
like him and two other guys
who smoked yeah my old apartment
we smoked we smoked bernies heavy
burnies in there they weren't great you
they you cracked the window there's
these they'd burn your eyes it was too
it was too it was too easy
yeah how did they do that in the 80s
and how did we not like remember that
like i don't know how are they smoking
right in front of us
in a car in the winter windows rolled up
heat on i'm strapped into a [ __ ] uh
car seat
just getting crushed with bernie you
were 12 too it was weird
[Laughter]
it was on the roof yeah
uh all right let's uh speaking of
bernie's from dylan you ever sell
cigarettes like single cigs to make a
buck what the what what is this we did
that when like you when you couldn't get
your hands on cigs and money was kind of
tough
like i'm talking like junior hot like
early high school a little bit when you
weren't like hey i smoked 26 a day type
thing you know what i mean
if
you i would have a pack sometimes and
people would be like yeah like i'll buy
you would sell like three for a dollar
or something to like you if you're like
i don't want to buy a pack or whatever
so you do that like two or you know once
or twice and you make a couple but like
if the packs were five bucks at that
like four something at that time you get
half a pack of cigs for free you know
your little get-rich-quit schemes in
high school really bothered me about
your book making operation what else is
what are you talking about
yeah we ought to do some things cut some
corners okay yeah i own five laundromats
that are very successful what the [ __ ]
that's what i'm saying he's giving me
[ __ ] for my earlier work
what the [ __ ] legitimately bothers you i
was trying i was [ __ ] trying hey
listen we all stunk but you chose to
wear a scarf okay
i thought that's what i was supposed to
do
i don't think i'd be able to direct
without it
all of your life decisions were based on
cartoons you saw when you were sick
[Laughter]
big fan of dynamite did you have one of
those cheerleader megaphones too
those old-timey directors had because of
one of those cranes zipping around
cut cut cut
fell in love with my star
it's cassidy
ah all right let's see here let's do one
of two morning we gotta wrap her up um
we talked about this but it's his first
question yo first time um long time
uh have you ever been called out for
your browsing history on a computer
which we've talked about before like if
someone sees something you were visiting
websites that you should have been
visiting someone's been like what's
xx.redhamster.org or whatever
i believe i was yeah
well i've been getting it off yeah i
don't know pop you all back in the day
you could always say pop-ups listen
here's the thing even now
you don't know
what's going on who has your wi-fi
signal who can tap ip address ip address
you don't know yeah so oh yeah you can
there's also
dobby cut this
plausible deniability as well
i've been hacked cut this and kill kevin
take his computer
um this one's from boner mcassell this
is
i just love how trashy the thought
process of our listeners is if we buy
stuff with your promo code then return
it do you guys still get to keep your
cut
that's [ __ ] hot that's great that
guy's playing chess i wonder if that
how that does work
we don't get paid per percentage
oh okay well what if i ordered 30
t-shirts waited three months and then
returned them
we have to give the money back
because that's not happening no no no
all sales are final over here at uh
kippy industries
um i don't know disappeared
i'll vanish right now
[Laughter]
i just turned to dust
he vaporized
the rock what a fun time yeah guys we
gotta wrap it up we gotta get out of
here we love you guys very much what
what a trip down memory lane that was
nice just never do that again
all right we'll move on from here
we love you we'll see you next week
peace